the largest investment the largest
expenditure that the average family
makes is your home real estate it is
therefore the largest possible blessing
and the largest miss you can make buying
it wrong buying it the wrong time not
knowing what you're doing and yet
everyone says buy house by house by
house by house as soon as you get like
four years old they start telling you to
buy a house if you are renting Oh Lord
you can't be a renter renters are awful
don't be a renter interventions are bad
you don't want to be a renter right and
you don't want to be a renter for the
scope of your life but there are times
in your life when renting makes more
sense than owning and one of those times
is when you're brand-new and you're
broke and you're young I mean you don't
have any money when broke people buy
houses you and make some broker why they
call them mortgage brokers you get
broker broker and broker when you're
broken you buy house
Murphy moves in your spare bedroom you
know that's the guy that can go wrong it
will and he brings his three cousins
broke desperate and stupid with him the
hot water heater goes out the roof leaks
dog gets run over in the street your
life looks like a country song you know
and it's what happens when you're broken
you buy house house is not a blessing
for broke people is actually the
month-to-month month in and month out it
can be more expensive to own than to
rent because if that four thousand
dollar heating air system goes out and
you're a renter you call the landlord
and go do your eating their systems out
and they just send somebody magically
over there to fix it don't they isn't
that interesting
but otherwise you got to wring your
hands and come up with four freaking
thousand dollars and that's very real
stuff so to start with let's just
establish when it comes to real estate
that renting is not a bad thing when
you're when you have a plan to get
yourself together financially you need
to be out of debt
need to have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses then save up
your down payment but a lot of people
get they get all hot and bothered and
they say stupid stuff like wow this is
stupid if you've ever said this you were
stupid I've said it I was stupid when I
said it I was stupid when you said you
were stupid here's just ready for this
well he you know the house payments the
same as the rent payments so why
wouldn't I own see that's stupid because
you left out the four thousand dollar
heating air system you left out the
taxes go up the insurance goes up and
you left out dot dot dot and so you know
it's really not cheaper and it is in the
long run because houses go up in value
and in the long run the payment if you
take a good fixed-rate mortgage doesn't
go up and rent does go up so long-run
owning is a good idea but on the
short-term for the first year you own
it's cheaper to rent most cases anyway
well there's you can't fight and then
people start coming around dinner and
throwing around all these absolute
fatalism crap and like I was forced
there's just nothing in this whole city
like like York City is weird or
something they're your cities and I mean
it's just everybody's got a place to
rent so when you buy and you put the
house on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
you basically have a forced savings plan
that's one of the benefits of owning you
also have it because you know as you're
paying the principal down you've got
this money built into the house called
equity your equity is what the house is
worth - what you owe on it and the
equity increases as you pay down the
mortgage obviously it's also an
inflation hedge now most of you have not
lived in inflationary times but I
remember inflationary times I got my
real estate license in 1978 inflation
was running 12% a year on houses I'm in
a house went up 1% a month in cost or
value cost if you were a buyer value of
you're a seller right and so if you own
property and inflation kicks in the
primary element of inflation is housing
there's other
car gas and cost of bread and that kind
of stuff but really the cost of housing
is your primary element it's one of the
largest chunks of inflation and you are
getting that to your benefit when you're
an owner and of course your home grows
tax-free up to a half million dollars
it's a tax-free investment
I have million dollars married filing
jointly it's the profit you can make on
a personal residence if you've owned it
two years or more that's pretty cool so
there's a lot of reasons to buy when you
get ready to buy don't buy the top of
the neighborhood buy the bottom range
your bottom half of the neighborhood
you'll get better appreciation there and
a better chance of resale when you do
get ready to move and when I took my
very first appraisal class in the real
estate business the guy in the class
said there's three things that create
value in real estate location location
and location I've seen a single-wide
mobile home sitting on a piece of dirt
that brought over a million dollars in
Malibu just north of LA yeah and some of
your really really nice houses aren't
worth a million dollars so that's all
about the location now it wasn't the
mobile home that did that it was a piece
of dirt it's freaking Malibu is
expensive you know per square foot
there's nothing more expensive in the
u.s. right now then
Manhattan and so those are views that
are our friends listing in New York you
got location location location when
you're picking out a home if you can
find something with a view it's up on a
little bit of a rise a little bit of a
hill or in the case of Tennessee or
those of you out in the Rockies up on a
big hill that view is worth you ever a
million-dollar view yeah that's that's
where this thing comes from people pay
extra for a view and if you're on or
near the water we have a little
neighborhood right here just down the
street from our office that's been there
since I was a kid it's 100 years old you
know it's called meadow lake now the
lake is no more lake than flat of the
moon it's a freakin pond
okay it's a little-bitty pond but it's
called Lake because this builder built
houses around it a bazillion years ago
the houses on one side of the street are
quote on the lake the houses on the
other side of the street are not on the
lake you would not believe how much more
the ones on this pond I mean Lake bring
more than the ones across the street if
you've ever bought real lakefront
property or beachfront property you know
if you're across the street from the
house that's on the beach or across the
street it's a whole lot cheaper there's
a reason on the water or with a view
anytime you can sneak into that into
your equation you're going to see better
appreciation and stand in the street and
look at the house and go is this house
just really ugly as it got bad bones is
it got bad curb appeal don't buy an ugly
house it's not gonna get prettier
because you move in it I have bought
some ugly houses and you know what when
you get ready sell them they're still
ugly houses they don't go up in value if
it's ugly it's just ugly all the way to
the bone
you know just use some sense when you're
doing this stuff let's talk just a
little bit more and then we'll take your
calls and I can realestate this half
hour
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're talking about the largest
investment most people ever make your
real estate purchase now I've bought all
over probably over 2000 pieces of
property in my life over 1,500 for sure
somewhere in there I'm currently on a
bunch of real estate I love real estate
as an investment built several homes and
grew up in the real estate business got
my real estate license when I turned 18
years old three weeks after I turned 18
backin way back in our 78 1978 so um but
uh so I've done a bunch of real estate
deals and to me it's all just a house I
don't really get all torqued out about
certain pieces of dirt some people get
all twisted up about dirt or a certain
piece of property or you know that kind
of a thing I mean there's the things
that I'm nostalgic about for sure and
thinking about but but you know it's
just a house and there's one on every
corner they're everywhere and there's
another one so yeah you just slow down
and not get house fever when you're
buying and you get all stressed out like
right now people are running around
they're you know there's like multiple
offers coming on a listing because some
of these markets are white-hot and
people get stupid just slow down
it's the largest purchase you're ever
going to make for most people as piece
of real estate and your spend more money
there than you spend anywhere else
slow down a good rule of them on any
decision making is this the small little
dinky decisions that you're making like
make them fast and then that leaves you
bandwidth emotionally and timeline is
everything else to spend time on the
large decisions you know people get in
line to buy they can't decide whether
buy clips gum or or or buy you know
dentine and they get all paralysis of
the analysis about their breath or
something and take some 30 minutes make
a decision on gum and then on the way
home they impulse a car you know
see that's backward you just it's come
you're not going to be pretty when you
chew it anyway you're just use or shut
up get the gum it's just gum you know
and then slow down on these big
decisions so when you're buying a house
do not buy the top of the neighborhood
it's just a discussion one of my leaders
stopped by my office while ago said I
was looking she was looking in a new
home a really nice property and just
concerned about the neighbor wondered if
it about what I thought about it it's
great neighborhood I think she'll do
great there but my first question is
you're not buying the top of the market
don't buy the top of the market and
that's in that neighborhood owned by the
most expensive home in the neighborhood
because it's harder to sell people are
not looking for that house that price
range when they go to that neighborhood
they're looking for uh notch or two down
and you want to be in that notch or two
down you'll get better appreciation and
have a better chance of selling it when
you do that and remember like we said
before the break there's three things
that affect property values location
location and location and in every city
they're those invisible lines ever hear
somebody say I grew up across the tracks
on the other side of the railroad is
that that railroad track wasn't it was a
an invisible line and on one side of the
railroad was where the poor people were
and on the other side is where they
weren't that's what they mean by across
the tracks right and so that's you know
that's what you're looking at and you
don't know where those tracks are if
it's over the city you don't know I mean
you look around sometimes there's some
telltale signs the way the neighborhood
has kept up or something but I grew up
in a neighborhood where it was nice
brick homes built in the 60s typical
suburban neighborhood and these houses
you know I went I was 16 years old they
were selling for forty five thousand
dollars now they'd sell for 145 probably
or 100 and 180 or something like that
but but say a hundred say they're
selling for $45,000 strangest thing the
exact same house same timeframe built
actually a little bit older was right
across the main drag a mile away the
main drag you know main artery of
traffic running north and south through
our city
and on one side of that artery that same
house brought five thousand dollars less
which is ten percent less it'd be fifty
to fifty one thousand on one side rent
we 5,000 oh there's 10% swing but but
square-footage
you know the the the items that you find
in the home the quality of construction
the age everything was very very similar
the only difference was one was on one
side of the run room was on the other
and it was perceived for whatever reason
to be slightly cooler to be on that side
of the street and people would pay for
it and people pay for it because people
paid for it and that's how location
Location Location centers into this and
again we said be near water when you can
and be near a view or with a view or on
the water when you can you're always
going to see much better returns there
and have a much more much more
likelihood of selling there you're
buying bargains when you're buying a
house you look for things that people
people can't look past the average buyer
can't look past the minor things and
minor things are things you can fix
easily like carpet or paint color or a
gutter hanging off you can put a set of
gutters on the house from nothing and I
hope I find the gutter hanging off and
the weeds are tall oh darn by a lawn
mower you know and get a deal on the
property you know and buy like a whole
truckload of lawn mowers for what you
save on this property
matter of fact you could hire people to
cut the grass for you is what you save
on the property right so but you know
take things like that I used to go into
property I would love seeing something
that was very poorly decorated or it was
a mess the lady didn't keep house well
immense there was a bargain because the
typical person can't look past the
unmade beds and the Elvis print over the
master bedroom bed you know and you
remember the old 1970s green shag carpet
we actually had rakes that we raked the
carpet do y'all remember that yeah I
used to look for that gray Keable carpet
because that meant it was old right and
then it was nasty usually and you could
put carpet in a house for nothing
compared to getting a bargain on the
house now I want to deal I'm talking a
substantial discount but these are all
aesthetic things paint carpet that kind
of even a roof you can put a roof on the
house
most of the time that's not that killer
all right here's one I love in the south
it's got termites and people just pass
out and flopping the floor and foam at
the mouth and everything else it's crazy
I'll just tell you there's termites
everywhere in the south it's humid and
they're everywhere and you need a
termite letter and you wanna make sure
the house hadn't been torn down by
termites but again I've owned almost
2,000 pieces of property the number of
times I've seen a house that was
completely destroyed by termites that
someone just didn't notice the house was
falling down you know it's almost zero
but I have bought deals on houses
because people got emotion it's God
turned by the infestation it cost me
three grand to fix five boards and I
bought the house forty or fifty thousand
dollars off because everybody got
emotional about a couple of white bugs
spray the crap out of them with a
termite company and you know replace
four boards and put an exterminator in
there it's not that big a deal you know
it's not yeah you again inspect it make
sure it's not falling down around your
ears but these things that people get
completely torqued out about or where
you find your bargains what you don't
buy is what we said earlier it's a house
it's ugly if it's got bad bones and it's
ugly from the street don't buy it
it's not going to get prettier and it's
not pink color we're talking the way
it's built it should about house should
not have been on that lot it's poorly
designed it's got the wrong columns it's
got the wrong front porch the wrong
elevation it just looks like crap and
you know what it's going to look like
crap the whole time you live there when
you get ready so it still don't look
like crap people are gonna stay on the
street go that's the ugly house and
they're gonna want a discount
a deep discount you thought you got a
bargain but it's not you're going to
turn and give somebody else a bargain to
get rid of it I've owned a couple of
those bad news don't do that and the
same thing is true with a bad floor plan
so these people they do what we call
country house they keep adding on rooms
and adding on rooms and there's no
architecture and so you end up walking
through two bedrooms to get to a
bathroom and all this crap and it's just
got bad walls you know the thing is just
pieced together it's like we're bolt
this on here we'll bolt this on the air
like a bunch of people drink through two
cases of beer and then
came up with an idea on how they're
going to add on to the house you know
it's a bad idea so don't get into that
use good real estate agents they're
worth their money use a home inspector
always get an appraisal and always buy
title insurance never buy a property
without title insurance it's worth every
dime there's a couple of pointers for
your real estate class for the day right
here on the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]